während zweier die lange genau die
richtige zeit für das fragen lotto die
grünen fragen sind harmlose fragen die
roten fragen sind gemein und diese
fragen ich darf sich darauf aufmerksam
machen dass dj ötzi in dieser rubrik
schon mal ein wutanfall gehört aber sich
dann auch sehr schnell wieder beruhigt
hat und die heißt wenn die roten sie's
musst du auf alles gefasst sein
ja okay das freut mich sehr
ich sage meine kollegen seiner begibt
sich auf dünnes eis ist berühmt für sie
als das habe ich so ähnlich wie wir sind
ja beide mit tapas aufgewachsen oder was
auch immer es war einfach das war der
straßenfeger und da haben wir von jay
hewing das gemeine vorbild auf der auf
der einen trugen beulen auf der anderen
seite was sie soll vorbild auf der einen
trunkenbolde auf der anderen seite was
bist du für einer
besonders riskant ist ja leider aber ich
sag mal du bist anders als vorbild
andererseits bin ich vorbild eigentlich
bin ich einerseits vorbild wir hatten
trunkenheit am steuer bei dir stimmt ja
sie aber vergangenheit an gibt es
vergangenheit ja denn dann droht
vergangenheit natürlich aber ich bin
nicht immer in allen sachen folge der
findet ihr nicht und ich was sagen deine
generation zu zu was hat so dass du
nicht immer vorbild bist peinlich
okay ich bin ja immer noch erwachsen
werden
peinlich für meine tochter vornehmen
kommt und so
und dann naja da okay aber ist alles
halb so schlimm
ok also du bist nicht erwachsen geworden
das kann man ja will ich gar nicht
verstehe ich habe ich mir geschworen
habe ich mal gesagt sogar ein großer
teil deiner vergangenheit wirst du noch
oft auf der straße in bezug auf der ja
auf der wellenlänge angesprochen fast
täglich gerade auf mallorca new york auf
jeden fall weil durch meine musik
erreiche jetzt auch ein jüngeres
publikum
ich hab so ein publikum von acht bis 80
ist wirklich so ich habe viele junge
fans und die älteren sagen
die kennen mich da nur von der musik und
fast täglich
ich bin ja nicht raus oder den straßen
ich bin letztes jahr der letztes jahr
miterlebt denn hier wieder eingestiegen
und wie es weitergeht da habe ich wieder
kommen oder nicht wiederkomme da habe
ich dir jetzt nicht aber du weißt was du
geschrieben hast
scheiß drauf mal ist nur einmal im jahr
ist es der begriff stimmungslage ist der
begriff stimmungsmusik nicht einfach
eine schöne version von nidda für
betrunken
die frage bin ich besonders gelungen
die ist gut die gut nämlich wenn man
spaß haben will muss man nicht unbedingt
1,2 promille haben um damit zu grünen
ich meine ich bin nie alkohol auf die
bühne vor der bühne lachen auftritt
vielleicht alle drei monate die ich
wirklich auch mal ganz gepflegt aber ich
mag die musik selber ich liebe und lebe
darf und wenn ich die nummer scheiß
drauf performe er dann so mit liebe und
leben in der woche alkohol führt ihn
aber auch die das publikum nicht kann
ich auf youtube sehen der einige videos
und auf myvideo oder clipfish wir immer
wieder leisten
wir sehen es gibt auch viele die nicht
getrunken haben scheffel
widerlich ausschweifen kommen du hast
einen sehr bekannten namen wie kommst du
damit zurecht die ständig im auge der
apk zu befinden
gerecht wäre ja mal gut mal schlecht
es hat viele vorteile
mittlerweile auch wenn ich bedenke wenn
ich die zeit vier jahre zurückdrehen
aber dass etwas kompliziert damit meinen
namen wenn man den namen im mund
genommen hat dabei aber mittlerweile ist
dazu herren wenn in den armen herum
hören dann fangen viel an zu lachen weil
wissen nicht mal gute show entertainer
und ich dir für kölsche mentalität und
fröhlichkeit und auch dafür dass man
wenn man ganz am boden ist auch wieder
aufstehen hält gucken ob die
fröhlichkeit bleibt wenn du jetzt eine
rote frage siehst
okay ich bin ein star holt mich hier
raus ist eine teilnahme am dschungelcamp
nicht peinlich wie finde jetzt ja ja ja
die letzten drei male fand ich schon
ziemlich bei licht und die wollen sie
alle nicht ich kenne ich nicht aber die
letzten drei male muss ich sagen fand
ich schon sehr peinlich dabei nicht
planvoll regenwürmer eine kakerlake ja
der spd hingegen sei um die heiß und
leben oder als lehnt und riesen made in
diesmal die war ungefähr so lang so lang
lebt so dick und man muss zuerst im
komplettpreis gucken und dann den rest
es hat aber sehr nützlich geschmeckt und
was keiner besser sind das drei denn
alles delikates habe ich nachher fragen
aber mir war es damals nicht peinlich
weil ich fast cool ist eine
herausforderung
dann kann man mal nach australien
fliegen und den dschungel erleben
damals waren auch coole charaktere dabei
ich hatte damals noch harry wijnvoord
kassen spengemann stehen den ganzen
gerecht
sie gab es mal war dabei dolly buster
die unselige da liegt über das ist halt
ja aber jetzt die letzten drei male ich
gucke es zwar auch immer wieder aber es
ist schon peinlich jetzt gehen die leute
dahin und sehen das als strom
ich könnte ja wieder karriere machen
oder wenn dann vom management wenn sie
überhaupt ein management haben oder wenn
sie management haben werden sie dann
geimpft geht da rein das so und so
bewegt diese und knackig aus die ganze
zeit also ist jetzt nur noch da
reingehen und sich irgendwie zu zu
profilieren
die sind jetzt peinlich brems ergänzen
hat der wird gehrig letzten haben beim
letzten stopp fernsehen ist das wird es
immer mehr momentan gehe und trend
langsam
ich finds auch momentan verletzte grüner
grüne dann erst auf den straße war 92
wie bleibt man so lange relevant im
showbiz ja indem man immer fleißig am
rollen hält und die leute müssen einfach
natürlich mögen das problem vermögen
wurde nicht mögen aber man muss ja auch
polarisieren
ich habe damals wohl polarisiertem licht
ist ein super lolli und ist ja
mittlerweile wirklich immer noch einer
der bekanntesten beliebten uhr in der
liststraße obwohl er so lange schon
nicht mehr dabei ist ja was war also wer
weiß
nein also man muss halt wirklich immer
sehr fleißig sein und sich auch nicht
nur eine sache konzentrieren also ich
mache hier sehr viele sachen was viele
kollegen nicht nur in der lindenstraße
ein dorn im auge weil ich halt
mittlerweile bekannter bin als andere
kollegen nicht viele leute dann scheiß
drauf verfahren ist nur einmal im jahr
in diesem sinne
gerne sehen